hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator
now it's been a long time since I played
this game and there have been boodles of
updates okay I don't know what this is
hi hello I don't know okay and I think
I'm ready for this I'm gonna go back I'm
gonna get out of here excuse me sorry I
came into the wrong place you have a
lovely day there oh my God look at his
eyes oh he's so cool yes now standard is
what I was always in love with in the
first place I don't need to change him
he's my senpai and I love my senpai not
a hundred percent sure where they even
begin
because I'm just gonna I've already seen
this thank you I know you can't feel
anything I can't feel anything
God so going into this I just want to
see what's new and I don't imagine it's
gonna be like all that much new boy I
just wanted to do for myself what you
get ready for it whoa a button
oh I pulled it off the ground and it
fell off of his own coat he left it
behind I think he left it for big
uh-uh-uh omen that won't be together
forever I'm gonna use it to staple my
face onto his face will be attached to
your button okay corkboard I'm gonna get
so many pictures assembly looks like
they turned off the town because there
was literally no point to it right now
why won't you love me everything looks
so beautiful now oh my god is that the
tree of love
I will love you forever right here in
the flowers oh my god it's [ __ ]
beautiful
yes I've got a saved that and I've got a
Photoshop sent by into that picture yes
yes did they change this animation
because this looks a little bit
different look
yeah where's my SuperSpeed with Oh long
long steps no the deal
ah still a robot for the club well let
me just explore the ax on my own yes
that seems out of it
flocks is it locked - my ax is it is it
locked
[Music]
one of them's our multi multi arsons
well not yet not to like it the lay of
the land what is that I don't know what
that is but I'm so down for that
whatever that is hello hello anybody
here anybody want to get dead
anybody want a high dive into an empty
pool please tell me that's an option
there is literally an actual force field
around the pool and you can't actually
fall into the pool or anything just like
you know oh okay well senpai will love
me now that I've ascended reality I do
lady that's cute okay all right scoot
Lee do I do later
a little boop beep my baby that oh oh my
god I can be closer to him than ever
senpai please turn around if you love me
turn around if it's true love
what happened whatever it's fine I don't
mind I don't mind out of mine it's fine
on the Art Club a cult club drama
cooking music Oh martial arts to be
giant garni sports gaming club yeah I
don't think so such a dreamboat Midtown
let me duh my cans and easier [ __ ] yes
oh god he's so beautiful cuz every in my
perfect man don't mind me said bite
don't be crawling up on you to me the
perfect snap point got it sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry what's up with me punk I
love you
alright good boy hi are you real oh oh I
probably shouldn't do that well here I
go anyway the wink all right okay oh
okay well that was easy
you're truly stupid he's just stupid
what's wrong with your face you're so
dumb hahaha I got the key do this like
right here all right don't look I'm
stealing these all right got it put my
hand out there you're gonna often ursy
wursy I got nothing I'm not gonna open
that right when you're in here I guess
maybe I should yeah you keep looking
over there I'm gonna do this whatever
this is open that take that close that
oh I don't know what I got but I think I
said anemic medicine
I don't know that is teachers hi hello
how's it going teaches hey what's up
what's up teach hey how's it going just
a student checking in on you love to
learn and learning is real cool I must
steal this right now right here right
now okay so this is the option to steal
something
all right okay all right okay oh hey
how's it going there hey how you doing
huh can I talk to you with oh nothing
yeah I would do I look like someone that
would ever misbehave I just love my
senpai too much to miss babe unless if I
wanted that and then you know ooh
what are you magical girl wand [ __ ] yeah
I can't use it what is this magical girl
costume it's dumb but I'm gonna do it oh
I shouldn't I should do that okay so
apparently magical girl wands is just
something that you could [ __ ] kill
people with great to know good I love
reality were sent by doesn't have to
remember how I killed everybody in front
of him Ruby dooby doo it's a good day to
be me all right well we got martial arts
still here whoo lovely see light music
what the [ __ ] what oh no no that's all
about
hell yeah hi the prey how do I pray
summon victim how do I pray do I need
something to be able to pray how do I
pray to you forgive sins please oh I
don't want any of these do
oh they're working Oh summon victim what
oh hi hello okay
oh that's what the selection is Oh God
summon weapon place of input power
should before us huge science what am I
gonna do with that besides make creme
brulee I info Chan are you doing let's
see if the roof is any different hello
hi
Oh gossip gossip gossip gossip gossip
what's going on over here spy I spy on a
[Laughter]
whole load of gossip here hi hello
you're neither you boobs McKenzie I
never did understand what all these
magazines were for there's so much like
it like whatever it plays game like it's
it's always this in the mindset I get
the new thing murder in the new way but
I've never actually like stopped and
explored everything like Who am I gonna
light on fire is that possible can i
there's a gas can
that's an option
this oh good dumbbell kind foot [ __ ]
a heavy weight can I just get a really
just [ __ ] drop a heavy weight on
someone Looney Tunes style here I wonder
I really wonder hang on here I've got a
new method for murder also that's 50
kilograms oh my god I'm so [ __ ]
dropped it they're right on my thighs
[ __ ] I am I am a goddamn Beast
ow
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] dropped it excuse me senpai I
dropped my 50 kilogram weight oh sorry
can I drop this on how can i I'm gonna
look up at a drop that's on someone
because that's what I want to do in this
episode right now [ __ ] yeah I'm actually
I'm actually right on time for it hang
on I gotta get to the roof I gotta get
to the real quick ow oh gee going to the
front now scoodle you gonna drop heavy
weight boo-boo
are you down there yeah you're down
there what can't I drop this you need to
tip over tip got it oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] oh I caught it with my ethical real
power clutch [ __ ] it go right down there
just come on [ __ ] do it will work I
can't jump there's no jump option IFRIC
gonna get an Baba crossing move
Mackenzie it's gonna be the best and I
love to be me gone up with this over
here
gonna put the cell [ __ ] got a split on
time because it's going too fast on
Annette whoops [ __ ] can't carry that
Singh and talk about murder gonna take
this job to do the roof now oh well slip
be slapping doors door slamming in my
face now going upstairs if I can just
figure it out I don't know how to walk
upstairs right now things goin way too
[ __ ] fast but he were gonna gun
doodle and she she they're not there I
boom can't eat come on hey buzz hang on
don't mind me I'm good take a second
truss take a stab at this here we go all
right boobs what the [ __ ] where did you
go Jesus crisis is such a [ __ ] now Oh
your aunt to drop it like it's bad damn
it damn it
that's supposed to work that's stupid
I'm gonna stab you and then you're gonna
be like oh I wish some would crush me of
my face not over there it's over to the
left more it's over to the left more
just a little bit come on you can do it
I believe in you boobs McKenzie I
believe in you I believe in you I
believe I believe in you believe that
you're gonna see away from them if you
just go just to hurt you just go to your
right come on oh come on don't work it
don't freak flip thicken worse it's
don't flip I'm gonna hang on I got
another idea to get you gone let me let
me pour the gasoline in this can your
bucket where are you boobsie oh there
you are I'm gonna pour you and then I
gotta be quick after it gets on there
Oh doh is it
gasoline shebanski flick and Wow this is
a tragedy why would anyone do this I'll
call the police immediately if there's
been a death at academi High School we
need help right away
oh [ __ ] oh God wait hey let me take off
these [ __ ] jeez she's still just hover
in there 3-nothing Oh your body hey do
you mind if I just take this body excuse
me what are you talking about what am i
doing you don't know what I'm doing oh
we know what I did I was just trying to
take the floor anyway so that is there's
a whole bunch of new stuff because I
believe that particular way of finishing
someone off was put in like last year so
there's a whole bunch of new stuff and I
want to go through it oh but it's gonna
take a few episodes to do it so expect
some more yandere simulator coming on
you very soon because there's more
schemes and there's more ways to get rid
of your rivals other than just murder
murder is pretty extreme burning is
pretty dream but she wouldn't be crushed
anyway so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know anything down
the comments below as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]